et on va retrouver tout de suite sur le
terrain notre envoyé spécial gulliver
crack gulliver bonjour en direct de kiev
on vient d'entendre volodymyr zelensky
il s'est longuement exprimé hier soir
adressé à des journalistes russes c'est
une avancée en tout cas dans la
rhétorique l'un dans ces négociations
qui vont se poursuivre aujourd'hui on a
eu la confirmation aujourd'hui en
turquie avec une chance d'aboutir
réellement
je pense que on est probablement encore
loin dans l'aboutissement de ces
négociations vu l'intensité des combats
qui continuent sur le terrain et le fait
que selon un sondage récent 78% des
ukrainiens ne pense pas qu'il devrait
accepter un cessez-le-feu tant que les
forces russes n'auraient pas quitté le
territoire ukrainien et le compromis que
volodymyr zelensky a évoqué contre d'une
basse en réalité est un compromis limité
il a dit que la condition pourrait être
pour commencer les pourparlers pour un
éventuel accord de paix la condition
pourrait être que les forces russes ne
quitte pas entièrement le territoire
ukrainien mais il se retire jusqu'à
leurs positions d'avant le 24 février
dont avant le début de cette invasion il
veut dire la ligne de front qui existait
dans le donbass en deux le territoire
contrôlée par les séparatistes soutenus
par la russie donc dé facto par la
russie et le territoire contrôlé par
l'ukraine donc il pourrait se retirer
juste à cette ligne là plutôt que de
quitter entièrement le territoire et
puis aussi il sous-entendait que pour la
crimée aussi on n'en parlerait plus tard
c'était ça le compromis donc il a évoqué
et non pas du tout un compromis
éventuelles sur le statut du donbass
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
discuter plus longtemps à l'avenir là où
la position de l'ukraine à bouger c'est
sur cette ambition d'adhérer à l'otan
volodymyr zelensky a clairement dit à
maintes reprises maintenant que
l'ukraine pourrait renoncer à cet
objectif si elle obtient des garanties
de sécurité ont d'autres sous d'autres
formes de ses alliés alors sur le
terrain pas de nouveau corridor
humanitaire annoncée par pour
aujourd'hui les autorités ukrainiennes
qui
explique redouté des provocations russe
pas de d'exfiltration de la population
civile à marioupol notamment le maire de
marioupol viande vient de s'exprimer il
dit redouter une catastrophe humanitaire
pour pour sa ville à kiev gulliver
où en est-on exactement au 33e jour de
cette offensive russe quelles sont les
avancées du terrain
mais d'abord je pense qu'il faut
souligner que la catastrophe humanitaire
à marioupol est déjà en cours et depuis
deux trois semaines déjà ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui pourrait arriver c'est
quelque chose qui est déjà arrivé et qui
continue mais pour ce qui est de kiev
pendant les derniers jours on ne parlait
plus vraiment offensif russe en
direction de kiev en ce moment mais de
contre attaque ukrainienne et des russes
qui essaie de défendre les territoires
qu'ils aient dès qu'ils ont déjà pris
mais ce matin les militaires ukrainiens
ont dit que les russes ont repassé à
l'offensive en direction nord ouest et
est de la capitale mais que pour le
moment les l'armée ukrainienne repousse
ses offensives et il n'arrive pas
vraiment les russes à avancer mais les
militaires ukrainiens ont aussi dit
qu'une résulte une nouvelle tentative de
reprendre l'offensive et la tentative de
contourner kiev par le sud-ouest dans
l'avenir à moyen terme dans les semaines
qui viennent mais avant cela selon les
informations toujours des militaires
ukrainien les russes se seraient retirés
en partie vers la zone d'exclusion de
tchernobyl dans le nord de l'ukraine et
peut-être aussi vers la biélorussie pour
se regrouper et pour préparer une
nouvelle offensive de plus grande
envergure pour essayer d'en cercle et
kiev merci beaucoup l'univers craag
notre correspondant ok merci pour